but yeah i've just noticed that like
since you know having the balcony and
having so many like new things to build
like that i i've really enjoyed building
furniture like un-ironically i'm just
going to show you guys
yeah i'm going to come to my house and
build my furniture that's all i've been
doing honestly dude i'll happily do it
it's actually so fun i don't know it's
like i bet he won't if you actually were
like joking around this time he says
it's on camera
camera turns off yeah yeah oh i'm busy
i'm busy that day oh no no honestly like
you like buy me lunch or something i'll
do it all right okay i'll like dead ass
help you out because you ever like
consider making your own financial like
pro going proper deals like buying the
water yeah
i have actually thought about it but at
the same time to make what i don't know
just something i don't know but like you
know maybe like a table or [ __ ] i
don't know whatever but like
i have thought about it
i have actually thought about it but
like yeah because i don't know like i i
took woodworking uh like classes a
little bit in like uni yeah um because
it was like a thing that we had to do um
but like i wasn't it's weird because i i
specifically remember i [ __ ] hated
that course like i really did not like
doing like diy [ __ ] yeah and it's not
until suddenly i've like moved and i've
got all this like i think you know what
it is it's not that i enjoy diy it's
that i like the feeling of getting new
furniture
so that that that just changed
drastically as opposed
but it's like it's i think as well it's
like it's nice because i mean you guys
have seen
me in this like trance-like state when
i'm building [ __ ] where like i literally
just turn on music yeah and i just am in
my own world as i'm like making
furniture or like whatever it is when
i'm making something it's like i think i
like that feeling because it's almost
meditative to me no i i like the feeling
of buying furniture that's that's that's
a good feeling you're like i knew i was
eating on my furniture when it's done
built like i knew i was old where you go
through the ikea catalog and you're just
like oh that that's a good that's a good
looking desk right there
now you're gonna go there in person guys
i'm gonna go to the ikea mega store you
gotta sit down you gotta feel the chat
furniture become fun dude [ __ ]
welcome to
i bought that uh that ikea grass [ __ ]
right yeah
it's just like generic grass that goes
on your yeah your uh
whatever the [ __ ] you want because i
wanted to have some grass so i could
like it feels nice yeah it's good feels
good yeah so i bought it
turns out though those ikea grasses like
the one thing that sucks about them is
that like you can't measure them
you can't like fit them in precisely
yeah right like they either fit or they
don't yeah i can nearly either have some
of your valve patio covered or you won't
right
they're like squares they're like
they're like ah i think they're like
five by five
oh you got the you got the squared tiles
yeah yeah oh i got the ones because yeah
i just got the roll because my balcony
is massive because ikea does like square
tiles of fake grass yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah and so i didn't really consider how
it would fit but i roughly measured it i
thought hours it will [ __ ] work
realize there i can't block the the
drain
uh the water drain yeah otherwise no
water again obviously so so so then i
was like okay well now i either have
like a big chunk of my patio not covered
and it looks weird yeah or i have my
drain cover which i can't do so why not
cover it with like there's there's
because i know the tiles there's like a
wood tile which has holes in it can you
just put that there i have some wood
towel on the other side okay well what
about if you get the square and you cut
a hole that perfectly fits the drain and
then you can just pop it on top because
that's what i did in my place oh okay so
what i did it's not it's not it's not
it's not like um one big drain the
drain's in the corner somewhere else but
it's like it's like the thing that leads
into the drain oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah stuff
needs to be carrying it yeah so i was
like okay [ __ ] i'll cut the [ __ ] in half
yeah it's it's it's like rock-solid
plastic right it is no i know it is
impossible to cut the shirt i was like
what tools did you use to cut it
my willpower i literally like got this
piece of plastic
it's like this big right like this not
even a saw i literally just like
bent it together with my hands like this
right and then i just kept bending it
like that yeah and it weakened and then
i did it the other way but the other way
it's all plastic so it hurts your hands
to bend it [ __ ] bending so i bend it
the other way and i just kept doing this
and it got loose enough where i got some
pliers and i was like cutting the
plastic along jesus christ
so god damn long and then i had the
problem of okay because of how these
towers work there's only like there's
two sides like the one 90 corner right
90 degree yeah this side and this side
are like the holes that you connect it
to and these sides have like the clips
that it clips into yeah so i had this
problem now some of it clips in well
some of it doesn't so i'm like don't
step on that one people when people go
to the balcony because i'm like uh yeah
you're just all gonna like [ __ ] break
and fall apart if you step by but it
looks nice yeah we got it yeah it looks
like i heard my hands and it took so
goddamn long
that's why i like the roll variety
because it's it's designed to be cut but
but like i didn't have a big enough area
to warrant a whole roll yeah yeah it was
a small area i just wanted grass i
wanted to see more green yeah yeah cause
i i in my previous place i just had like
the wood things oh those are the wood
towels which look nice but also i
thought i just prefer the feel of fake
even if it's fake
oh yeah it feels great yeah yeah that's
why i got some parts wood just for to to
have that over there i was like oh
i got grass for where my feet go
something about with touching grass with
your feet feels good
what can i say we touch grass yeah they
touch grass every morning next time you
consider insulting me remember i have
grass and that i tell you whenever i see
even if it's fake yeah whenever i see a
comment that says touch grass i'm like
don't mind if i do it i got out of my
balcony
so much girl
do you have a garden in australia when
you were growing up do you regardless
yeah my dad had a massive garden oh yeah
my smile my now now that my dad's
retired it's like all he does yeah
gardening would you ever consider a
garden
i know i want a god i don't want to look
after said god that's the point right
the idea of a garden is nice um because
we have a garden in our uh english home
as you know you've been there um and
there was a point in time where my
parents would just go to thailand and
there was a point in time where i would
work from home um at that house and then
in the months that they were away i was
just i noticed
that the garden just progressively
looked like [ __ ]
and the grass would grow and that was
that at that point where i realized
oh someone's got to take care of this
garden for it to look good
i don't want to do that that's that's so
much effort it's a big garbage plants
are alive
plants are living things
and
ever since you know ever since then i'm
just like the idea of a garden is nice
but just i've seen a lot of people like
sydney's house has like a massive garden
and you can lose like half a day or
something just like taking care of it my
dad regularly spends multiple days
taking care of multiple days like he
loves it though it's like it's like his
new child but it looks amazing to be
fair he does a really good job but to me
it's just like i think i would
absolutely love it if i had the time to
take care we haven't got to that age yet
we can appreciate just being able to
like pull out the lawnmower you know
have your coffee or your beer and just
just go at it yes exactly just just grab
a hose and just hose down is that a good
thing i don't know like when you get
older you'll probably enjoy those
pleasures more yeah because because
because i remember when i was a kid my
mom would be like go on go cut the grass
now it's it's your turn and i'm just
like [ __ ]
they never made me do that they have all
the other choices oh they made me do
that i [ __ ] hate it because to me it
was my dad's life he's not i'm not
letting him do it it's my garden it's
it's mine he's gonna [ __ ] it up
my dad was like if you don't do it then
no dinner tonight and i was like okay
yes father and i do it and i i i hated
it i wanted to do everything else
that's why i like the fake grass i'm
like
i hated putting out the laundry that's
what i hated i still hate putting on the
laundry well sydney does actually
certainly love that [ __ ] but the way it
was in my house is that we had like just
a line and a big stick that props up the
line in the middle yeah
yeah so it was always [ __ ] annoying
when it was windy doing this when i was
like like small as well and this pole is
massive so i hated doing it
memories by the way i don't like doing a
laundry now that's because of you
[ __ ] hate that poll piece of [ __ ]
they still use this poll as well
get a new poll get better upgrade your
poll look at the new poll like i
remember i remember uh when i moved to
my new place and you know because one of
the biggest thing about my new place
that we've added um
is a dishwasher which uh as you guys now
you guys have dishwashers now right yeah
i sure do completely changed my life and
my mom at the beginning my mom was like
my mum my entire life right has been
like we don't need a dishwasher our
family doesn't need dishwasher yeah like
that's that's just that's just what
that's just wasteful water that's just
like your water bill and your
electricity to be always going to go the
moment i found out the dishwashers use
significantly less water i was like well
that's my excuse for the rest of time
i'm like i'm never ever ever washing
your head yeah i'm like you guys you're
like you're killing the environment i
can't i can't
and ever since like i've moved into my
new place and like i've shown my mum the
dishwasher and just like how much less
effort it takes to you know wash dishes
after you cook like a zoom call with it
being like mom look
i pressed the go button
she's like um yeah i could be looking
for a dishwasher for christmas
conversion complete
i was like where where where was this my
entire life mom was i just your
dishwasher my your entire life and now
that i'm gone you you need an actual
dishwasher is that it is that it that's
pretty much i see how it is mama i see
how it is children are just cheap
appliance like conversions right this is
like i could spend a lot of money on uh
you know a lawn mower yeah or i could
get my son to do it with the shitty
lawnmower honestly one when i have
children you bet you're asking my
describing why people had kids like
hundreds of years ago that's why they
had so many they're like well i can't do
it when you get married into a house i
was like all right how many things do we
need to do every day seven all right
prepare to have seven kids paying for
this i'm not paying for an assistant i'm
getting a kid
hiring a cleaner that's like privileged
rich people [ __ ] getting a kid
that's the real [ __ ]
that's a wi-fi